[Music]
hello
hola sidetrack your sci-fi tv and movie
channel what the hell was that noise
i think somebody just booped it wasn't
me
um
we're here for our normal fortnightly
live show with my resident american
matey old stormy over there
hi
works there's a link in the description
can you hear me because i can't hear you
i can hear you
take them out so if we hear kids we hear
kids don't worry about it
right
are you back with us
and um i am glad to be here
one sec
there we go we're back i'm very happy
we're happy
just as uh to warn the viewers i am a
snot rocket this week so
please disease
yeah but please upload pity
[Laughter]
so we're probably going to get viruses
through our computers now all storm is
false
so
first of all before we get into it we're
going to have a little bit of a chat
about
what we've watched this week
um and then
we'll get into the topic of the week
which is firefly series two or what if
we can fantasize about if only if lonely
if only
because i've already done a video on
watching picard series one but episode
sorry series two episode one have you
seen it
yes i have is star trek back
you know i kind of liked it
i actually i really kind of liked it you
know and
i'm sure we're going to get hate mail
for that from somebody but i actually
did kind of really enjoyed it you know
and especially you know q snaps his
fingers he's back to the um
the 80s visage of uh
oh it's just let me catch up
quite like that
wasn't the best cgi in the world but for
the budget and everything else i think
is pretty good but um but now i i
honestly i
the general consensus on a lot of
groups and stuff online seems to be that
everyone loved it and everyone thinks
star trek is back and this is the star
trek we actually want to see they
listened to the fans we all got very
angry at the end of series one you were
very angry hell you made videos about it
your anger
i was very very angry
but they seemed to they were listening i
think the makers of star trek alex curse
or whatever listen to this so
[ __ ] brilliant brilliant i've got
some guy barney rubble saying that this
is click bait fireblade series 2 by
seawood
they haven't even started yet calm down
see he won't be subscribing we're not
worried he's right so what what have you
seen what else you've been watching this
week before we get started so this week
i binged space force
i've been space force as well i quite
like that show
um that was uh entertaining
uh ended too quickly you know there's
short episodes you know and john
malkovich i love him as an actor
i mean he's just you know
yeah he's one of those lovely blacks you
can't help but love him can you yeah
yeah yeah and it's just um
well when you're doing red
yeah it was so almost out of character
for him
you know and um
but it he did it brilliantly
do anybody want pancakes
i've watched you sweet i've started to
watch resident evil uh resident evil
present daily in series two
that's going to be a nice segue into
what we're going to be talking about
this evening and because alan tudyk
stars in that um resident um alien
i think it's one of the best sci-fi
shows on tv at the moment
i honestly do i think it's it's i mean
it is funny it is a comedy but um but
it's just
brilliant i just adore that tv show i
don't i i laugh my way through it it is
sci-fi as well and there's some very
actually very clever little bits of
science fiction in there um
and alan tudic is just fantastic
yes and yes he is
which is a nice segue like i said almost
on purpose
into what we're going to be talking
about this evening barney you see
clickbait we are going to talk about
firefly series 2.
yeah again hey now he wished he'd stayed
now didn't he
um
the other thing i was watching was uh
uh
discovery some of the newer episodes of
uh discovery yeah
and
huh i've not watched any yeah
okay
spoilers away but the ring
the the the death match
in the ring
that was very entertaining
it was just
fun to watch everyone was topless with
sharp weapons pointy sticks
the problem over here is in the uk we
have discovery but it's on a tv channel
it only shows it at set times like
old-fashioned like we're back in the 90s
again so it's at nine o'clock on a
friday
i'm busy
i can't i can't watch it when i want to
watch it what is this communist russia
we watch the war when you're when you
when it's on tv oh i will watch it when
i want to or not at all damn it
so perfect
so we'll get into it right so i've put a
poll up on um
the channel the community channel got
last time i looked we had 132 votes but
i was asking basically right so if
there's a firefighter series two and
we're going to talk about it today or
we're going to sort of fantasize about
what we would have wanted in the series
too
i could see that we had a couple of
options so we could either completely
ignore the movie serenity and by that i
mean so the show
was never cancelled
it just went through and what would you
like to see in the end of the series one
going into series two what would you
want to see
or i
thought ross whedon said that the movie
was basically where the first series was
going to go
so let's ignore that wash was murdered
pretend the movie is like series one and
then all that then a series cracked on
straight after
the movie
or the third option is canon's canon
wash is dead it breaks my heart to say
that but um and then you know we but we
got a season we got another series two
after the movie so we've got those three
options there we go
unfortunately the people have spoken
this is a democracy
and over 50 of the people said no
cannons cannon
so what happened happened wash is dead
people yeah there's a warning
as a leaf on the wind that's been
speared
into a wall
um
so yeah
we he didn't either leaf on the wind
done
um
we'll talk about that briefly though
right because
they made that movie
and i think joss whedon only killed wash
for an emotional impact i think they
knew the series was done it was never
coming back so they murdered wash
yeah
now they're talking about a reboot in
disney this room is constantly going
around that they're going to do a reboot
and it'll just be a tv show called
firefly and the the ships will look a
bit like firefly they don't have no
electric but if they were genuinely
going to do a reboot a couple of years
ago
if they hadn't have killed wash and got
alan tudic to do it i think that could
have got made
oh we could but they killed him
do you think uh if disney does
a reboot of that
do you think they'll go hardcore woke on
it like well mal
reynolds will he be like i don't know
some um
some short little girl
that's dressed in you know
freely anime cosplay
stuff
like woke brown coats why would that be
woke though if it was oh just changing
her
changing his gender changing his gender
identity changing his orientation
john would be really weird as if they
changed jane's gender
so jane was a woman that would just be
like
the heroine of canton
[Laughter]
the heroine of canton
james
the woman
stood up to the man and she gave him
what for
we love her now hard to explain
the heroine of canton the girl they
called jane
i'll stop call singing voice gorgeous
gorgeous
you're drunk
um
i would have so let's go with the
fantasy then all right so okay
um
i would love to know what if
how would series 2 started see that
we've had the movie the movie was a
massive success so they have
given us a second series
um how would that second series start
because i've got
i've got a brilliant idea how this
series could start can i can i just run
with it can i just tell you what i think
go for it
so everyone the ship
so it goes into the ship
you know they do those brilliant
wandering rounds shots that they do
right right right all the different
rooms and things
everyone's running around jane is
freaking out going like there's gonna be
loads of blood there's gonna be loads of
blood and panicking sort of thing
um mal is sort of like getting bit
medical equipment stuff and and um
simon's sort of like in the thing get it
get her to the meds get her to the net
but then it pans across and it's zoe and
she's having a baby
she was pregnant with wash's baby
we're going to talk about saffron in a
bit because i want to i want to give i'm
going to throw out
to a couple more reading
i don't know i know right but i actually
think so he was pregnant in one of the
comics so i think i might have stolen
this idea
um but yeah i just think that's how it's
because it's got to start like though as
if they're under attack or something and
then right right shot in the head of
something you know somebody's bleeding
horribly um and then you know it shows
you
so he's having a little ginger baby
so then and then we'll call it wash
again because obviously wash is his
second name got a little
quiz question for you what was wash's
first name or what was actual anatomic's
proper name in the series
uh last name was washburn
and yeah first name was
holland oh you are so close
holmen
hoban
yes
hoban washburn
yeah
um but i think that's how that has to
start ah see we've got some sci-fi
firefly fans in the
in the house very good yeah um
what do you think about that then i
think that's an obvious start but god
right
yeah
yeah i mean you know it would um since
you know um
wash is dead you know murdered had
stabbed through the heart with it was
just just his body ruined and torn
asunder
let's have a little baby
little baby you know
i want to see
jane as like uncle jane and you know and
then um
that that would just be awesome i could
i think there's there's a lot of comedy
elements to that thing you know that was
the main thing with the series it was it
was funny and it was quite sweet in the
way you know jane's character was um you
know obviously a very violent character
but
they always had that
that um streak of kindness you know
sweetness to him i just didn't look just
in him trying to pretend like that
stupid baby and then like cuckoo
and he loved mother
yeah exactly and i was trying nara
trying to deal with it and things like
that with you know i just think it would
have been would have been a really nice
way to start serious
so when a reality point of view though
the
alliance is not happy with the crew
of the firefly
um
we
i think series two would pretty much
be dealing with a fallout
from that thing wouldn't it
yeah um
i mean you know
essentially it was genocide
yeah most definitely um well it was
trying to control the population and
planetary
genocide
very clean genocide yeah
so i mean
the thing i loved about that plot and in
serenity though as was because there
isn't a government on the planet that
wouldn't go for that
they wouldn't be like you know we can
put something in the water and it would
calm everyone down
no no not the obviously the murder bit
really what they were trying to do
you know i was like can't we can calm
everyone down have no violence everyone
to just do as they're told
what a buddha
everybody take their boot up hill
exactly you know there's a big um sci-fi
a conspiracy theory that's why there's
so much fluoride in the water because it
makes us
a bit dopey
um but you know i mean it's i think
there isn't a government on the planet
that wouldn't do that give enough chance
oh yeah yeah but the alliance not the
nicest people in the world so um but
how do you think
they would have reacted because in the
movie they sort of say uh they're not
looking for you they've got bigger
things to worry about but let's be
honest
so spiteful people in the government
they're going to want to
they're not going to be happy about that
either
um i definitely think the the government
would try to [ __ ] their [ __ ] up
you know i mean you know they did let
the rabbit out of the
cat out of the bag
and really ruined a good thing that they
that the alliance had going
you know and now you know the alliance
is going to have to improve magnitude uh
the alliance is now going to have the
problem of um
dealing with the repercussions of the
reavers
how many billions of credits has the
reavers uh
how much damage have they done to
general alliance shipping
you know private and public
uh
i mean there there's a i mean yeah the
alliance does have their hands full
but that doesn't mean there's a
department that's got you know
a picture of mal as on a dart board
you know
i think it doesn't seem like the
alliance forgets its enemies very easily
i suppose it's just a big organization
but i'm still talking about the reapers
though they're going to be uh rivers
rivers are reapers
um they're going to be quite relatively
decimated i mean that was
a large chunk of their fleet went head
toe-to-toe with another fleet
um it's one thing about the movie i kind
of was a little bit
um
disappointed by i loved the way they did
the the the alliance ships
in the series like they were those
cities like they were like buildings
yeah in space you don't need to be
sleek and you're nothing and they they
didn't do that in the movie and i was
like that was a bit of a bit of a shame
it wouldn't have it would have looked
crap in a film really i suppose but you
know it's just like um
shame they did that but the the fleets
the ships they had were pretty cool um
but
you got to wonder how many of the
reavers were actually wiped out so are
they is that name be not going to be a
problem
for the next series or
would we still see the beavers or
there's going to be a clean up now
because everybody knows what they are so
well i guess the yeah it's
um
did they get them all
um
was that the only planet you know while
there was this tribe yeah it could
that's true
but we i mean we know from the series
the reavers were pretty much ignored
they were like the the alliance tried to
pretend like they were the boogeyman
that you know that they didn't you know
they weren't really a thing but um now
obviously everyone knows they'd have to
try to deal with it so i mean that
that's gonna again be a big part of the
second series um i think
i think the series two would have
started with them just trying to survive
i mean they were on the edge anyway
but now
they have to steer clear of everything
alliance
how would they even survive the next you
know 12 months you know on the outer
planets
um
if the series had gone on i'd have loved
justin maybe another um
uprising sort of thing and you know an
attempt to actually get freedom again
but um but too i think it would have
just been about surviving
you know
i could see where there would be you
know the opportunity for uprising and
there could be a fracturing
of the alliance or maybe the outer
planets have just had enough
you know and there's nothing to say that
the outer planets could also seek other
systems to uh
move to
you know you know the alliance
may and in the outlying planets the
brown coasts
find another system
and then there's the static between
those two groups
we'd have continued to see i think the
the week on week episodes because
obviously in the first series they were
struggling to survive just trying to
make money and trying to you know keep
flying
and obviously would have seen that but
it would have been more difficult i
think the baby there would have made um
you know something for them to actually
you know fight for a little bit
yeah
how about some of the characters then
where do you think
do you think they'd have carried on the
will they won't they between mao and
inara wouldn't they you know there is
some um oh yeah you got to be better now
no yeah definitely there are some rumors
or theories that inara was actually sick
in the first series
and then in the movie and that's why
they didn't get together because amara
was knew she was dying
so um i think that could have been an
interesting storyline to say that she's
you know
she's got some media
i guess it wouldn't be like a syphilis
or anything i i think it was space
cancer specifically considering her job
well
some sort of deadly space std
um
but but yeah i mean
there could have been a million
different things but it would have been
something that medically they couldn't
fix something but i think that could
have been a really interesting
um
development as well that if you know
towards the end of the series they have
to try to save an hour or or even an
hour dies because
by all already by them um trying to
remember her name
marina baccarino baccarina
the gorgeous mariner anyway right so
beautiful she's so gorgeous um was
already becoming quite a big
star sort of thing so she could have
been
poached maybe but but i i think
i quite like that theory that maybe
that's why she left firefly and and you
know maybe that was why she was at the
temple
you know the companion temple and he was
trying to get you know healed from
whatever space surface she had
this basically that's not a thing let's
face it
yeah i'd say all the master ones are
going to be up there having
they're going oh my god we all got space
syphilis
and
so would have loved to have so what is
earth is like now after the split is a
habitable or there's something there at
all earth baron and
yeah i think that in the in the series
that kind of suggested that the earth
was sort of depleted and yeah the earth
that was as it was in so i mean to be
honest it's probably all right by now
because you know
if we left the earth would recover
probably quite quickly yeah that's the
problem
with it
yeah if we would stop shooting nuclear
power plants
exactly yeah with fighter jets and
artillery
shells let's not get too political you
know start at this time i said what have
you been watching this week my first
thought was the news a lot
yeah bbc sky news uh france 24 yeah
i get the bbc news alert and then so
just a little red box that appears and
it's a news alert but it doesn't tell me
what's happened it just says news alert
and every time i'm there going oh god
um but yeah let's get back to
firefighters that's why we're here
um
we'll have a um if we need a channel for
the news just like we're all screwed
oh man bitching about the news
and my knee hurts genuinely money hits
um
and i've got snot rocket
space syphilis in your face
um
oh
god i hope there's a cream for that
you
you know in season two you know uh who i
would like to see more of
yeah
badger
he is on my list of is he
he's i got a list
honorable
mentions because you know if
if the alliance is running into problems
you know i think badger at least you
know the way the character was written
for the
two episodes he was in
he could take up
it would be a great many opportunities
for a badger at least on persephone at
least on persephone
but yeah
bad people would have gone into the
criminal element a lot more the window
they would have had to have maybe took
on jobs that
they started to in the first day they
took on jobs that they did not want to
do and mao didn't want to do but
they
would have had to have gone deeper into
that another character
that um
have to remind me did niska die he
didn't did he
his buddy did the big tattooed guy got
kicked through the jet engine
yes
yes but niska is a character that that
that that is one of my favorite episodes
in real series
where um their mouths getting tortured
and keeps getting killed and brought
back to life killed i would have loved
to have synonymous particularly again if
they're being forced to do jobs more and
more that they don't want to do
could that have brought them into
niska's world a bit more
because he's a character that i thought
was fantastic i'd love to see him come
back
yeah
there's there's a lot of opportunities
there i mean you know
where would you want to see them go
what kind of
branch of the story would you want to
see
develop around this guy
i just think
he was just such a violent psychopath
wasn't he that doesn't think anything
that if you get dragged into their world
particular again i'm trying to i'm
trying to think about they've got this
baby they're trying to protect as well
and i think that would maybe be an
emotional element to it that i think
would be interesting
and you know that that they were a
family weren't they but that's going to
be even like like boiled down and like
even more now because of this this child
in there i just think the threat of
niska would have been interesting but i
think it would have to be similar to
that one episode they've done a job
niska's got maybe they didn't know they
were working for niska and this guy
would have a bit of a revenge
wanting you you know we want to sort of
get bit back at him
um
like for the life of me i'm not i'm now
panicking thinking i can't remember how
that episode ended with niska but i'm
sure he's still on the space station
they went in and they they they um
they they dealt with it
i've watched an episode literally about
a month ago somebody get into
the comments like uh niska is the one
that
has
mal's picture on a dartboard what if
he's the one
that wants to annihilate the rest of the
crew what if you know the terms for the
alliance
uh you know
book's dead yay and then the other
alliance said wash is dead but now we
got a baby wash
and uh maybe the long-term seasonal arc
is uh niska not getting baby wash
or babies that would be good
because again he wouldn't want to just
kill mal he'd want to torture mouth one
way of doing that might be to take his
family away from him yeah i mean that
would be a brilliant way to and you know
to build up towards the end of the
series or when you know it's like
mid-season sort of like double episode
sort of thing
i think i think that i'd be really
threatening really good let's go back to
badger though um
somebody's back in the thing said mark
shepard makes everything better
it's one of my favorite bit part actors
and a british actor as well because you
know we all love the british actors um
oh god there's another one coming in
there someplace i'm so sorry okay like i
said it's not wrong
um
drink a lemon
um he was in leverage quite a lot he was
fantastic in that yes i've been in a few
things since he's he's great in
everything
um
did you ever get into uh supernatural
i never really watched supernatural
we've seen that as well too
yes i got it i kind of missed it and
then i tried to watch it but halfway
through and couldn't quite get into it
and
i kind of missed the start
yeah he uh he plays the character
crowley
the war of hell
on occasion
the supernatural was a very long very
complex story
really
yeah
i love the guy from that the one the
longer head one of the two is now um
uh
texas trains what is that um
walker walk a texas ranger in a prequel
that's gonna be i i will watch that
actually i used to love to watch it
there's nothing better than a gower on
like take your
honor of your name or a um
how goes going with that garam memes
and uh i forget i've lost my mind like
my
thingy
have you been taking michael
is that what's going on here i must have
been i'm drinking alcohol yeah
oh i see well you know critical events
are absolutely right supernatural is
worth watching just for crowley
yeah
it's uh
and then there's his mother
[Music]
oh my god jason's mom
yes in in in in supernatural
okay oh it's j oh
see i've got so much to watch
and i i never got into supernova but i
was always told i should and i never did
but anyway
it's gonna be a long haul binge man
just settle down for the summer
yeah
the other
bit character that i would love to see
returned and if we have had a second
series on absolutely soon we would have
done
where's christina hendricks saffron
that's one
so i forgot
i would watch series with i would watch
anything with christina
anything she could just sit there
telling me off and i'd still just
happily sit there watching it oh god um
she's one of the most beautiful
gorgeous women on on the planet in in in
tv today i watch that bad girl she's in
i don't watch the show i have no idea
what's going on i just watched christina
hendricks walking
um but yeah the saffron character was
just stunning and she was funny and
again that's the one of my other
favorite episodes um was the one where
they get the the um i can't always call
this rubbish or something it was a
trash when they um get their oh my god
yeah and now starts off the episode just
makes it in the desert
yeah
yeah
that went out
yeah exactly that is again one of the
great too
saying which episode is greater firefly
is because they're all brilliant
but
i wouldn't have minded seeing a return
of the um
the bounty hunter as well from one of
the episodes that wasn't shown
and i think it was the last episode
actually wasn't it the um that the
bounty hunter guy that kept talking to
himself um
oh his name's gone and that's gonna book
me because i know his name
somebody in the comments will tell me in
a second but um harry is a proper psycho
and um
yeah he kept talking to himself
it's the guy that was also in
torchwood
i always i'd love torch would you
you know he was one of the crew
i would just love to see him come back
as and but like need the cruise like
need mal's help for something i think
that would be quite good i'd quite like
to see that in one episode so he comes
back and he's got like a job forum sort
of thing um
i think that would be a good episode
there's so many things that they could
have done diamonds
yeah canceling this show generally makes
me angry
i mean it was one of the dumb i mean
fox news right
we fought the fox broadcasting
corporation
they they got it
they
paid all the money to film it right and
produce it
then they showed it out of order they
switched nights twice i think you could
never find it any and you know there was
not streaming there's no such thing as
streaming back those days
it's like i just wha you know you know
you see the commercials every single day
well where's the show
um
exactly yeah
didn't they keep skipping it for um
uh
like baseball and stuff as well didn't
they do they keep skipping weeks and
things and all sorts yeah it was they
just you know um fox just was not
serious about
uh promoting the show i mean it was just
like they filmed it and it's like oh
let's get rid of it
i do think there was a there was a
problem in the way it was because i i
remember seeing this advertised and i
was already a big fan of um
of nathan fillion i thought in buffy his
character in buffy was just the priest
the psycho priest was just fantastic
well but i used to watch two guys
building a pizza place before that they
did the sitcom that ryan reynolds
was in
um and and he was great in that i just
thought this is a really likeable actor
he's gonna he he will do well here
i watched a free guy this week just uh
since you mentioned
ryan reynolds the sequel is on its way
to be officially announced this week by
the looks oh really
yeah the script is pretty much done
apparently and um
they're uh they should get yeah they're
looking a bit in greenlit this week
hopefully um but yeah i mean
nathan fillion was just
it's just one of those actors straight
away you just knew
there's a lot of things he can do
yeah
um he's a comedic actor he can do action
he can do anything um so so i knew
nathan fillion and i was already a big
fan and i saw firefly advertised when it
first came over here in the uk and it
was only unlike the sci-fi channel over
here which isn't a big channel over here
it's like one of those it's like 200 and
something in the um
on the cable thing
um and i just thought not cowboys in
space it looks stupid
um even though i was a big buffy fan i
was a big sweden fan you know and i just
thought it just looked silly and it was
the way it was advertised it just
it was horrible yeah it didn't
it didn't grab the flavor thing which is
why i was saying that if firefly does
come back they could do with tone and
back a little bit on the cowboys in
space
um but i don't mean
they should take it out of the show i
just mean they shouldn't advertise it
like that too heavily because it looks a
bit silly
um not that that would be a problem
though now really though because um
you know um
dark matter did get shafted you banged
on that that was a great show
really good
um but you know it's like they need to
turn back on the advertising and
advertise it on what it was it was also
advertised like it was a screwball
comedy sort of thing over here
and again it's not
um
but enough people have fallen in love
with it in the 20 years that's going to
make you feel old
20 years since this show was cancelled
um
you know it's like
they um
two decades
dude you have to keep repeating it
really
yeah
20 years ago did you hear it stormy i
said it was 20 years ago
two decades
do you know the only reason i actually
watched firefly though was um i went to
hmv i don't know if you've got that in
the states the the record shop hmv
hmm
yeah it's it's just sells dvds and
records and things um so i went in hmv
and they had
stacks of the box set i mean like
stacked up in the doorway 20 pound
for this this box set and i thought i do
remember seeing advertise you know what
for 20 quid for like 15 episodes i'll
have that
i i halfway through the first episode i
was just like
perfect where have you been in my life
because because this show is better than
chocolate it's just
it's just
fell in love and by the time i'd watched
um the train job
yes
there was just like
i i've literally been i actually phoned
in sick and binge watched
firefly that day i found it my boss
who's like oh
because i'm poorly what's wrong i want
to watch firefly i mean i've got a cough
yeah
i was i pretended to be you
and i just fell in love um if anyone get
in the comments tell me have you caught
firefly did you actually watching the tv
or did you catch it afterwards i'd love
to know what people oh
and you know i didn't see the whole
thing until i bought the box set
yeah you know
at that point in the time i wasn't
attached to the tv
with your tv but i was wanting to see it
and they kept i mean it was
you know
i didn't get to see the whole thing
until i bought the box that i know it's
terrible
if we talk so well so we've talked about
the couches you want to see return want
to see your skin we want to see badger
we want to see saffron
and you know we think that this baby
thing would be good i think
inara might die in our series 2 version
of series 2. um
i think there's so many good obvious
obviously shepherd book will be
returning
simon tan can return tam can return or
not i really wouldn't care or notice
um
because it'd be halfway through
seriously simon and somebody else
you know i mean he could actually go do
real
research [ __ ] now now that the uh
uh
i mean he was on the run from the
alliance trying to cover up the secret
of miranda
well everybody knows about miranda now
him and river could actually get along
in you know with life
river i would say river would river stay
with him would river just stay with the
crew
well him and kaylee
are an item oh that's where we're going
yeah okay he's pregnant now kaylee's
pregnancy
everybody's pregnant
river's pregnant and we don't know about
who and jane looks all very sick
baby nursery now on board yeah
because i have a room
like a pink baby room with it and but
yeah that would be an interesting that
would be you know because i loved kaylee
i love jewel states i don't know why
she's not been anymore she was in
stargate for a couple of seasons she's
great and i don't think i've ever seen
anything since
and i did look her up once she'd i think
she's just some sort of um drama in
america i don't think ever came over it
but um
and she is buff that girl works out i'm
telling you man she's done some some
some setups in her life yeah simon's
pregnant as well
i like that
it's the future anyone could be pregnant
these are um currently she's on some
shows called family law
family law there guys i'm bored i'm not
watching it
um but yeah that's woke babies men can
have babies
um
i'd love to talk to you about but
obviously they're talking about doing a
reboot
well no no they're not officially
there's been no talk about reboot but
the rumors
going on and on and on and you mentioned
it being woke earlier
uh hi sean how are you sir
um you mentioned it being
woke
it would be wouldn't it
they'd woke the crap out of this one
though
i know you know me i'm not a big fan of
work i think but i think people get very
very angry about this i think some
people that are
have isms at the end of their name
because they're racisms and sexisms and
they use this as an excuse to get very
angry about tv shows sometimes i i we
don't want to get more political today
but
from
let's just say current world events that
everybody and his brother is paying
attention to this last week or so
i think you know
we're
entering maybe a post woke era
you know these little complaints that
some people have are really kind of
seeming
small
maybe infantile compared to
uh
greater issues you know
i mean you know it was
two thursdays ago was at the beginning
of world war three we don't know yet
and so i think i think some people just
say well you know maybe there's
something else i should be worried about
then you know
what's in mao's pants unless of course
it's saffron
yeah that's a mental image i've now got
thank you thank you very welcome
i should just let's just have a moment
of silence and think about that for a
minute um
this show is not woke but yeah i'm gonna
problem with that um
i i i do think that they'd
it's on disney
now disney can make some terrible tv
shows but they can also make some
wondrous tv shows if they get the right
person in charge
the most recent rumor i've heard is that
john favreau is going to be given a
crack at it
um i immediately went piss off you know
how many star wars dresses got over the
next couple of years
um the only way john favreau is doing
this star firefly series is if he
desperately wants to do it and he's
basically begging to do it other than
that
yeah it's a nonsense but but it was on a
podcast and apparently they've got an
inside source that's told them this is
what's happening
um
i i will have to apologize if that's
true because i might have i might have
said you're full of
[ __ ] well yeah
you know it would be nice if somebody
actually you know had
if if there was a firefly project
somebody it had its uh the creators of
full intention you know they were fully
attentive to this show as opposed to
15 different star wars spin-offs of a
bunch of marvel stuff
a bunch of marvel stuff and who knows
what else is going through the boy's
head
that's a good point that critical saying
saying actually
a lot of the sets might not
kind of you could kind of run them
together and you'll have good ways
taking out the moisture evaporators and
the tauntauns and you know you're good
to go
you know actually that's not a terrible
idea that's genuinely not terrible
um
i i the only way i think firefly could
possibly come back
and be a success i think i'm absolutely
certain it will come back at some point
i think it's too popular there are too
many people that still today after 20
years go on and on and on about five oh
we are that's why we're talking about it
yes um because we love the show so it
will come back at some point
um
but for it to come back and be a success
um while nathan fillion tried to
actually buy it he he genuinely did try
to negotiate to buy the rights to it a
few years ago
and he was in an interview and said you
know basically if i won the state
lottery a 100 million dollar sort of
thing which he's worth that anyway but
anyway if i want to i would buy firefly
and i would make a firefight series he
loves the show
you know um so the only way i could see
it coming back is basically if nathan
fillion got on board as like an
executive producer or something and like
pushed it through you know after the
rook is finished he's like i i want to
make firefly
um maybe not a star in it but i
desperately want to make firefly or if
somebody like john favreau that can
basically go to disney and go you know
what i've done a really brilliant i've
done the mandalorian for you it's been
massively successful i've done you know
i basically i directed this this and
this before
and then basically he's in a position
where he can get what he wants
yeah and he wants to do it like not just
maybe jeff i was somebody like that
somebody's gonna go into disney and go
i want it
i want to do it and that they you know
really adore the hey mike from whale yes
you're only about five miles from me
um
you wouldn't have do you know where
wales is stormy
yes i do oh excellent well done just
check that's kind of you you've kind of
got scotland and you have england over
here you have wales and over here you
have ireland and that little patch of
island called northern ireland it's very
awkward forever
and that's the bit that we sort of went
we have this bit this was the irishman
um yeah wales is where the um the sheep
and the hills are
wales is generally one of my favorite
places on earth uh cardiff is in wales
is that correct
if ever you come to england now and you
go hiking
wales is the place to go you will get
rained on a lot
but you'll love it it's beautiful
absolutely beautiful northern scotland
wales are the two places to go but
anyway
um
i've got my train of thought again now
what we're talking about firefly firefly
coming back nathan killian's a gentle
guardianship
i'd love to see what nathan feel you
could do with him
he's produced a a couple of good season
a series now you know he's a big he's a
big part of what makes the rookie good
he produces it you know he's he's
involved in that something i think he
could do something with this i don't
know if like say i don't know if he'd
star in it i think it would have to be
like firefly the next generation
but um
i think he could do something
interesting i mean he he is definitely a
talent i mean he's had the fortune to be
on
three really well four if you count
buffy really good television shows it
had longevity buffy firefly
uh
castle and rookie
yeah
ten seasons
yeah i watched a youtube video goes on
all of the firefly mentions in castle
and it runs for about eight minutes this
video and it's just like constant little
little mentions obviously you've got the
him coming down dressed as mal and his
daughter goes what are you supposed to
be a space cowboy something
you wore that five years ago move on
something and he obviously loves the
show
and that was a completely different
audience most of the people i imagine
watch castle at the time went what what
but uh
um
but yeah i think nathan fillion could do
something with this um i think if john
favreau if that rumor is true and he
genuinely wants to do it i think he
could do something pulling on it um i
think he's a very imaginative filmmaker
i think he's um
[Music]
i just don't see it i've never heard him
say he wants to and i don't know where
they've got that from but
um
i suspect he was just a youtube video
and got a lot of hits i suspect probably
so but um something i get accused of a
lot
so you're just making stupid hits
because yes because i sit around
imagining stuff that's what i do it's
like
but anyway um
i i don't know anybody else like i said
i think it would require somebody that
absolutely loves it or because if you
don't have a showrunner
somebody that comes in joss whedon isn't
going to be allowed to do this
he is a pariah
in thing and i can't imagine disney
going near him with a 10-foot cattle
product at the moment no what i know he
was
accused of some
bad things
but what how did that all that settle
out i never got the real skinny on any
of that it never really there was never
really like any form accusations he was
just basically just a lot of people's
rumors that he's a bully
um i saw
an interview with spike um
his name's gone another english great
english actor spike from buffy anyway i
saw an interview with him and um
and he says he banged heads of joss
whedon loads of times when joss whedon
at one point had him against the wall
telling him you're [ __ ] this in
[ __ ] they're getting out of here get
out you know you're dead sort of thing
and then he went on to appear in the
next five seasons and because the
executives loved him they just we even
wanted to get rid of spike at the
executives
and then obviously joss whedon
eventually sort of fell in love with him
like we did and ended up
getting into angel and whatever
um i'd love that i came back as a ghost
maybe gosh could come back as a ghost
let's do that
um now anthony head was um the
headmaster was the teacher wasn't he
right
yeah um
my martial masters
no it's that's eminem
something like that it's something
martial masters or something like that
um they're an air near an ear there
now
exactly
go ahead sorry i'm just i don't know why
he's singing but anyway um but yeah he
was in if he said he was going to start
but
the joss whedon did executive and and
write a bunch of the nevers which is
actually so so that was actually really
good i really enjoyed that i don't know
if it's going back for a second season
or not but it was really good
um and he left the show halfway through
and nobody knows why
but the rumor is is because he was being
a bit of a dick
let's see the nevers
yeah is that the is like um
is that the show kind of a
victorian era yes
uh these are these women this thing came
across there's a spaceship come across
and it gave more superpowers and things
okay
loads of mysteries a lot of questions in
that show we never really got any
answers but um but you know i i loved it
it's great it must have been uh last
year or even the year before i don't
know if it's coming back but um
but yeah he left that and apparently
there was some accusations that
women weren't very happy with him james
masters thank you mike dear god that
would have bugged me i knew marshall
masters wasn't right but i knew it
wasn't a million miles away either um
so
um but there will have been accusations
and charisma carpenter has made
accusations that she basically ended up
in therapy because of him
um she says accusations that she was
basically suffering ptsd
because of the way he was now other
people have just said he's passionate
he's a passionate filmmaker and
sometimes his passion got away with him
a little bit
um
other people are more sensitive some
people like like spike could get away
with that like james moss has got away
you know could could understand that and
marshall james masters actually said
that in this interview that he's just
passionately never really took it
personally but obviously some of that
charisma carpenter did take it
personally and she struggled for a long
time but afterwards
were those accusations though i can't
see disney in particular going near him
yeah i understand now yeah
but um that's
that's that's sad because i actually
think he is a brilliant filmmaker um i
loved the first couple of avengers but
then obviously he went into um
justice league and completely screwed it
um they had half a film and he just went
in and went no i'm just going to take
everything you've got and i'm going to
ruin it
yeah i i i kind of did just like
basically hate justice league
i would rather take nails
and shove them in my own testicles than
watch the original justice league again
but the um
i'm also very predictive when i say that
normally i stick my finger in my eye and
twirl it around when i really really
don't want to do something i don't know
why i put nails into testicles but
i was trying to be graphic and i really
really don't want to watch it
um
but this jack snyder or zack snyder cut
was actually quite good i actually quite
enjoyed it i i i didn't like that i mean
it was
oh man it is
it's a complicated thing with me i just
it wasn't just too long it was just
too much
you know i mean it was like
it was like somebody took out you know
the middle of the bible of the old
testament
and just
mixed it all up
you know and just
yeah i don't know
it was confused in places though because
obviously they didn't do any more
filming
yeah like there's the bit at the end
where the marsh the mars
guy comes the green fella comes down and
there's no reason for it he has a chat
with batman and then he bugs off
no reason for it but
it was it was what was supposed to be in
the original and obviously they couldn't
record so yeah and there are some bits
in it that are just mental but
it was so much better
but say what
dc
have not been able to make a good film
until the new batman the new batman is
excellent
um
genuinely genuinely really good um
dc have not been able to make a good
film for that i watched wonder woman
84 recently
that was very painful
um
that was actually almost unwatchable um
batman vs superman
other than the
why'd you say that name a bit that was
pretty good but i mean
now i don't i don't want to watch any dc
movies aquaman i love jason momoa and
even that was crap
um everyone winner no aquaman is really
good watch it i was watching going you
lied to me this is right as well
um
but you know but actually batman's
brilliant
um but but yeah i just can't see
joss whedon's never coming back anyway i
just i just don't i just can't see it
and a lot of people say that if josh
reading doesn't come back they don't
want to watch it they would rather
firefly didn't come back
and um
well i will help
arrogant people i'm sure
yeah i mean it is here's a i keep seeing
this a lot
i saw this come up a lot with uh the
book of boba fett
fans
have this uh
relationship with
whatever franchise it is star wars
batman
whatever
and they feel that they have ownership
offset property
and they don't
um let me there's a guy there's a guy i
want to uh
talk about here for a second let's see
what was he it was a
i know i know i'm burning up time let's
see it's
okay
it's called phillip
filler that's right
james cameron writers
uh
see
the terminator was written as a kind of
a short story by what was his name
um
[Music]
i wanna see if something can get in the
comments before you can we're probably
saying yeah jerks
um
just don't bother
myself i haven't plucked up the courage
to watch any dc movie
just don't
i think you're saving yourself some
save yourself some time to be honest but
go watch the new batman because that is
brilliant
so we've been arguing that new batman's
woke because um one of them one of the
bits in catwoman says that you white
privileged people deserve what you get
and was that's woke the bad guy's just a
white guy i'm like
no white privilege that's kind of a
thing
um yeah kind of
ellis is the author i'm thinking of
harlan ellison
he wrote a short story uh about that and
um
about terminator about the ideas and
he's credited to the end of the film uh
ellison had kind of this vibe on that it
says you know
an artist doesn't owe the fans anything
you know the art sits behind the type
well by then it was a typewriter you
know and just cranks out stories after
stories after stories
you know there's nothing you know if you
write one story there's no rules as you
have to write ten more right after it
and uh he said i i know other
you know readers of mine want to see
more well i've got other things i want
to pursue
and i think with
you know these big franchises especially
started with star wars
and um the uh
fans
feel that they deserve
this that or the other and it and you
know like um
where i did i liked uh book of boba fett
because it showed a transformation of
you know this badass
darth vader kind of groupie
that
really just got fed up with how his life
was
was taken in by the the tuscan tribe and
it changed his life
and that was the story
but the fans wouldn't have it no no no
they want to see the violent
ill-tempered
you know
they wanted to see the kind of the bane
character you know
um
they wasn't interested in you know and
then they blamed it all on disney they
blamed it on the actor they blamed it on
whoever
but you know they just couldn't accept
maybe something you know maybe you know
uh
he was just more than two-dimensional
maybe he was more than just a killer
you know i think he said with any story
though you're not going to make anybody
happy yeah everybody happy i should say
you're always going to annoy yourself if
they do something different they're like
why are you doing something different
the original works if you do do the same
again so i'm gonna go why is doing the
same again it's boring do something
different so i mean it's like whatever
you do you're kind of screwed yeah go
back to firefly they're going that's
going to be a risk with this if they do
the reboot and it comes back
it's going to divide fans because some
fans will go brilliant i just want five
five to come back let's see what they
can do with it i want to see a show that
doesn't get cancelled i want to see
maybe let's see what we should have had
first time around
and then there's going to be just as
many people going just leave it alone i
don't want to see another bloody reboot
and to be honest
i'd be i
i'm leaning more towards that way
i'm sick today reboots and remakes and
reimaginations and prequels i hate
prequels
they just need to leave alone
um
fireflies is i think it's a huge risk if
they bring this show back
um because i think it was it was this is
gonna be controversial now
oh god that controversy
i don't understand it
firefly
is not really a very good show
it's it's not particularly it's very
well written the the lock is great the
special effects weren't very good the
actual general plot wasn't particularly
very good but what was amazing was that
family of actors that they got
and and the and the way it was written
joss whedon's words the the writing
was phenomenal and it was just like it
was one of the the greatest ensemble of
characters a family of
characters on set that is just
it's one of the greatest things that's
ever been put on on screen but actually
lots of parts of that show shouldn't
have worked
that's true
you know actors you know if so
um there's a lot of actors that you've
given [ __ ] lines they will make magic
out of it
yeah
exactly yeah it had the right people and
sean you bang on them
yeah
i feel that with my with this channel
tomorrow sometimes i get comments like i
don't like that i don't like this you
need to stop doing that and that's the
one i like the best i i had a um
an edit thing that i used it was like a
staticky bit and i i quite liked it
between cuts
right i've had two or three people
saying i don't like it stop doing it
at one point i don't mind somebody
saying you know that's a bit irritating
i don't really you know don't really
personally i don't really like that
but they don't say some people say
they'll tell me to stop doing it and my
what i want to say is
this is my channel
i'll put
what i want on my channel yeah
but you know you got to try to be nice
to people
i don't know why i bother to apply some
to english you're you're you're too kind
yeah i should just go you know what i'm
just going to have do a video just of
that staticky thing all the way through
and that's it i won't say anything um
but now
um but i've i've i've bowed to pressure
and i've changed it i've changed the way
this edited
i don't know why i didn't i might bring
it back now i've talked myself
i think we figured out what would what
would what we would have wanted in sears
too i think so
um
i won't see everybody pregnant
yeah
and um
and there is those few characters would
have loved her soon to come back you
know they've been all of them but you
know a few of those characters would
have loved to soon come back
and um i would love to see where jewel
um stayed kaylee ended up
and with um that that is the only reason
i want simon even in the episode is
because i just want to see because it
was so cute together
i'm gonna live bam bam bam the only
thing we haven't really mentioned though
is the story arc with
um river
because i i think that was sort of
fizzling out i'm not sure quite sure
where that would have carried on going
if she'd have um
well you know i mean she she got a uh
at the end of serenity
you know it was definitely
into chapter one
you know she was cured of whatever
craziness
she had the i'm guessing psychological
deep psychological trauma yeah being
able to recall miranda
and then uh face it go there to miranda
and face what they've been hiding
[Music]
you know
and you know now she they're free to you
know
uh explore just what she is mentally
capable yeah
and the thing is we would have
been other secrets she'd have known
yeah and she'd have she was mastering
her violent tendencies but
but
but
is the end of our show this week again
we are going to keep these around an
hour if it kills us because we would
talk about everything
um
but we've figured out where we want to
go thank you guys for everybody's got
into the comments today mike shawn
quickly then and we've had a few of the
regulars in as well like ian and so on
so um
a new one natalia
and pretty name so thank you guys for
joining as always even though you are
dying and on your deathbed stormy you
have made it along and we've listened to
you snot your way through this not in
your way through it man just for you
dude but you made it you made it
so thank you very much guys get into the
comments afterwards so it's anything
else you would have loved to see
also get in the comments and let me know
or or send me a message on facebook you
can join us on facebook at sidetrack um
there's a link in although my videos i
don't think there's a link on this one
but you know
um what other stuff do you want us to
talk about what things do you want us to
talk about um
uh we're going to do this thing where we
talk
we'll talk about what we've seen during
the week we'll have a topic and then
we'll do a little you know what have we
learned this week we've learned that
everyone's going to be pregnant if they
bring firefly back that's the main thing
we've learned
um and then we're going to [ __ ] about
something random and then we'll [ __ ]
about something random well we'll see
where the conversation takes us because
we always just wonder and as soon as we
should because this is our show storm
yeah we can talk about whatever the hell
we like
even if a young man right at the
beginning let's just fight to see if we
can find him
in the comments
um accuses us of clickbaiting so
oh well
um barney just
goodbye
um
you ass
stormy get well mate we will thank you
in two weeks
two weeks thank you two weeks seven p.m
greenwich mean time which i need to be
telling people because nobody can figure
out because we have viewers all over the
world i mean literally really well so
which i do which just astounds me
whenever people say hello
um i did have a guy called
um where you from telford you're kidding
me that's where i'm from
so that was a bit of a thing so yeah
normally people say like south america
and stuff like that but no okay um but
yeah so guys yeah tell us yet sean in
the us thank you um tell us what you
guys want us to talk about and we might
pick some topics
stormy
sir my friend
see you in two weeks again i appreciate
it
my resident american my favorite
american person other than um
and everybody good night guys see you
soon hey guys thanks for having us